I want to thank Rachel for inviting me I
am sorry that we can't debate uh that I
couldn't debate the uh Cordova
initiative the executive director I know
they were scheduled to come and withdrew
I would have appreciated the opportunity
for uh some Interfaith
dialogue uh specifically I think we're
here to discuss the ground zero mas and
before I go forward I ask only that you
be
open-minded that you listen not wait to
speak I'm not saying that to be
condescending I just want you to hear my
position and I'd be happy to answer any
an no questions I will um actually keep
my remarks somewhat abbreviated so that
I can take as many questions as
possible first and foremost The Ground
Zero Masque is not a religious
issue at no time have I or anyone that
opposes the building of a 15 story Mega
mosque in building that was destroyed by
the planes in the attacks on Ground
Zero about religious liberty at no time
it is an issue of human compassion it is
an issue of common
decency here yesterday we uh
memorialized the 69th anniversary of the
December 7 Pearl Harbor attacks 69 years
the second largest attack on American
soil second only to September 11 at no
time in these 69 years has the Japanese
ever asked to build a Shinto shrine at
Pearl Harbor nor would
they it would be incredibly offensive
and deliberately
provocative and I insist that the ground
zero mosque is deeply offensive and
deliberately Pro
proa there is no actual need if if we're
going to talk about need for a moment it
is it is not a residential
area there is a $75 million Community
Center going up few blocks away in Valle
Park
City its name is deliberately
provocative
Cordoba
iconic of Islamic conquest over the West
now I know that you're probably thought
that Cordoba was a golden age uh golden
for who exactly it certainly was not
golden for the Christians and the Jews
who lived under uh the Shar under
Islam they lived as
disis under dude denied basic human
rights it was the site of two Jewish
prams thousands of Jews were slaughtered
kadoba does not evoke for those who have
an accurate knowledge of History an
accurate knowledge of History uh
anything but Islamic imperialism over
the West so the name is deliberately
provided and the building is Ground Zero
it's not 600 ft from Ground Zero it's
not around the block from Ground Zero it
was
destroyed in the attacks which is why a
$25 million building went for $ 4.87
million and I am insulted at the
dishonesty of the argument I'm insulted
that we're told that Sharif Al Gamal and
and Imam R speaks advocates for
tolerance and yet in his book he
advocates for the Sharia which is
radically intolerant radically
intolerant Islamic law I'm sure the
girls particularly here have some
cursory knowledge of sharia and women
living under Sharia in Muslim
countries it's not
pretty so the question is
not a religious Liberties issue the
question is why there why
there it is causing an enormous amount
of pain for the victim's families and
yet we're told this is a mosque of
healing well clearly it's had the
opposite effect I know I I I um work
with these families an enormous amount
of pain and yet this pain is dismissed
with callous indifference
this pain and grief is
dismissed with with with with with with
an
intance imamu refuses to meet with the
governor who wanted to make some kind of
a deal to move it which by the way I do
not support because I don't believe my
taxpayer dollars should be used to fund
any house of worship I believe in the
separation of mosc state so I don't
think the government should get involved
unless it's a land use issue
but by the same token you see the New
York City Council has declared December
14th as banned at hate Walmart day
they've succeeded in stopping Walmart
from building in the city this I do not
understand what did Walmart do but not
the point it's it's there's hypocrisy
there you don't want to get involved in
the ground zero M but you're stopping
Walmart from coming into New York City
which by the way would provide jobs how
many is Untold and give the poor
an opportunity to purchase things they
couldn't purchase
regularly but we're not going to do a
warm thing yet it's just the
point now those that speak against the
mosque have come under brutal attacks in
the media yes myself included I'm not
complaining I'm just saying I am not You
Can't Kill the Messenger there's a
problem yes whether you like it or not
those attacks were inspired by chod
today as we speak arrest was made in
Baltimore by a Muslim trying to blow up
a military training center last week
25,000 people were targeted women and
children families in Oregon at a
Christmas tree
lighting there's a
problem there's a problem 20,000 Islamic
attacks since 911 across the world
there's a problem so if you're building
a center dedicated to Healing why not
build a center dedic ated to the 270
million victims of Jihadi Wars land
Appropriations cultural annihilations
and enslavements over the past
Millennium or why not built an academic
center dedicated to expunging these
teachings these violent
teachings but building a 15 story Mega
mosque looking down on the cemetery of
ground
zero is an
insult is
provocative
and you you have to ask yourself where
is the reciprocity we're constantly
being schooled in this hypers
sensitivity in the Muslim world don't
run the Danish cartoons 12 innocuous
cartoons Danish cartoons no Western
media would run them not one
why because they were offensive I've
never seen the media care about being
offensive have you it's a self-imposed
Sharia you can't run the Danish
cartoons you can't say the word Muhammad
on Comedy Central and South South Park
you can't put Muhammad in a teddy bear a
a Huggy Bear costume so
one liberal unknown cartoonist heard
that story in in in in Seattle and said
well everybody draw Muhammad
day not knowing what she was stepping
into within 24 hours she recants Molly
Molly narus she recants and still
there's a fatwa on her head not only a
fat but she's had to go into
hiding at her own expense lost her job
lost her name lost her home lost her
life nobody you ever hear of Molly Nars
how many people you ever heard of Molly
Nars okay she should be the poster girl
for free
speech so we're constantly schooled on
this hyp sensitivity in the Muslim World
where's the
reciprocity this is offensive to
non-muslims and Muslims of conscience I
have many Muslims R me that say it's a
bad
idea that's it I don't think the
government should get involved
I don't think it's a religious Liberties
issue I think it's a common decency
issue if all of us did everything we
wanted to do under the
law it would be chaos so how do we all
live together in a Multicultural
puristic
Society by being
kind by being aware of your neighbor by
doing unto others we have them do unto
you that is essentially the argument
against the ground a mask not there
there there are hundreds of MKS in New
York City there are thousands of mosques
in America it's not a mosque issue it's
the very idea of putting a mask there
when you have the St Nicholas church
which was taken down by the
towers established in
1916 and they cannot rebuild and you
have the
mayor Expediting this pushing this
project actually lobbying the Fed
for taxpayer funds from the 9/11 Lower
Manhattan Development Fund the 9/11 fund
they want $5.5
million here they said they wouldn't
take any taxpayer money now again part
of the morphing mosque narrative keeps
morphing every time we say something it
morphs it was a mosque it was a mosque
on the Cordova website now it's a press
space a press space is a MOS we're not
going to take foreign funding now it's
all going to be foreign funding we're
not going to take taxpayer dollar and
now they're applying to a 911 fund it's
not near Ground Zero has nothing to do
with ground zero but now they're
applying to the 911 Redevelopment fund
for funds to rebuild so now it is Ground
Zero so I would like to hear your
thoughts I would like to hear where you
are in this I know that I don't know how
many of you have investigated it with
any depth if you just take just taken
the the the media at its at its face the
media is incred incredibly dishonest
this you must see in your own lives and
it must Propel you it must Propel you to
seek the truth don't take my word for
it look up Cordova read sir Martin
Gilbert Read Ian
war read the mecan versus the Midian uh
chapters of the Quran and and and and
the second book supersedes abates the
first book where these teachings are you
must know because this is your future I
will look upon my parents and my
grandparents as the greatest Generation
because they saved the world they did I
don't know how you get to look at your
parents and I know how your children are
going to look at you but it's something
to think about because things are
happening big things are happening
nothing happens for decades and decades
happen in a day and then you scratch
your head and say how did that happen it
was right there in front of you you you
have to read the tea leads a little bit
but uh two story mosque at Ground Zero
will be Mecca on the Hudson because it
is it is an Islamic pattern to build
triumphal mosques on the cherish sites
of conquered
LS thousands upon thousands of triumphal
mosques the most obvious the most
egregious in my opinion was the first
temple the holiest site in in Israel the
very first temple King Solomon's Temple
first temple and second temple they
built the Dome of a rock right on top
the Jews can't pray there
now uh the St Sophia the most
extraordinary and beautiful Church in
the the world is now a mosque thousands
of Hindu temples in India thousands of
mosques so because one guy says that
he's building a mosque of
healing it'll be the first mosque in the
history of Islam and I don't believe
that the
1.5 uh billion Muslims in the world are
going to see that as a mask of
healing but let me take some questions
if there are any questions on this
issue yeah um you just said earlier
about there should be efforts to expain
the violent elements of the Quran how do
you feel about violent elements that
exist because you know if You' ever read
Revelations if you've read the book of
David
Leviticus um you'd be hard pressed to
find something more violent in terms of
how Christian should relate to other so
if you're for this sort
ofensor the Quran why is there not push
for the censorship of the Bible I don't
I don't really know much
about did everyone have a
question uh first let me say
this the violence described in the Old
and New Testaments are by and large
descriptive they are descriptive the
violence in the Quran had and are
prescript
it's a world of difference now if we
move out of the realm of of just talking
and you look at concretes because as
much as you're taught based on
assumption
concretes reality is really all that
counts because you can avoid reality but
you can't avoid the consequences of
avoiding reality and I don't see
Christians Killing In The Name of Jesus
on a daily basis five wait wait wait
wait five upwards of
five upwards of 5 to 10 Islamic attacks
a day I do not see I don't see it and I
don't see the Jews doing it either I
mean I'm talking about actual people
being slaughtered I'm talking about
genocide I'm talking about Christians in
Indonesia and Thailand and the
Philippines and Ethiopia and Somalia and
Lebanon and Israel and Europe I mean if
you're referring to you know Muslims
having history of BU
you know these triumphant M how are you
ignoring like European history where you
know Europeans
inan P expelled Jews yes and they
expelled Muslims yes so to me it seems
that they both have this sort
of history of I I don't know but no I
understand but but and I I agree with
you and and there is egregious acts in
history um but those are the last Wars
right now we're living in this period
right now and right now there is a war
on the west there's a war on the west
now it may not be presented to you that
way uh you may have to you have to be
maybe like Helen Keller and they move
the furniture a little bit you're going
to have to sort of read the tea leaves
you're not there is a war on the west
and while that war centuries ago
absolutely to your point did indeed
happen this is the status of the war
today and I don't see how that mosque
won't be Mecca on the Hudson I don't see
it the sight of the largest attack on
the west yeah um well you talk about how
we've got this award today to consider
um and how that should be a basis for us
not supporting the building of mosque
don't you think that's a very
reactionary philosophy and that if we
just keep going based on the case of
what happens to be happening in the
current then we're going to be you know
possibly expunging valuable freedoms and
ideas just because some antagonistic
group has you know made it a less
advertising to the American public well
I don't suggest that we censor anything
and it certainly cannot be me or it
cannot be the West that reforms uh these
these Islamic teachings this must come
from Islam this cannot come from us just
as the Vatican 2o uh The Period of
Enlightenment uh for Christians and The
Period of Enlightenment for Jews I I
believe Islam needs the same kind of
Enlightenment but it doesn't matter what
I say this must come from within the
Muslim world and we must support these
voices I don't believe that by
supporting um Islamic supremacists over
the the moderates and the reformers is
the correct strategy I think it's
enormously harmful and harmful to to
Muslims and non-muslims alike look who
has suffered more at the hands of jihad
than
Muslims I mean more so than non-muslims
so yes I believe that in these reform
and I don't believe that we can do it
and no I do not believe in censorship
but I urge that there has to be some
criticism and some cander about Islam of
which there's none you cannot criticize
Islam without being called a racist
islamophobic anti-muslim V
cannot yeah um I just don't
understand shes all over the Pacific
like a lot more troops Japan a nation
attack us I don't understand as far as I
know I'm not
like
places where a lot of
Japanese I don't even think they
japanes har I just don't
understand there's no shindo shrine at
Pearl Har yeah I know there is Pearl Har
was the site of the attack it was the
site of the largest attack at that time
up until 911 I just don't think it's
accurate okay you can debate the analogy
I think that it's pretty I mean you want
to go point for point I think that
there's no shindo Shrine and nor have
they ever asked to put one there and I
18,000 g
and I understand because this was the
this was the attack that started the war
it's very iconic it's very symbolic look
targeting the World Trade Centers was
also very symbolic and I iconic because
the World Trade Center was iconic of of
the financial power superpower of the
world targeting the Pentagon was iconic
of the military superpower of the world
and targeting the White House and or
capital building was iconic of the
political power of the United States I
mean the only reason why that didn't
happen was because they took off late
and the the heroes the American Heroes
on that plane was speaking to loved on
said no you're not being hijacked you're
in a
missile you are you are you you are and
they went in and they they they risked
their lives and they died taking down
that plane so I I I think it's symbolic
yeah
you so where what
you anywhere
else away anywhere else not a building
that was destroyed at Ground Zero it's
just very insulting and to pretend that
it's not or to say you don't you don't
get it I mean it's just it's logical it
just doesn't belong there and I think
look a piece of landing gear is in that
was in that building until up until I
guess I guess 10 or 12 months ago the
human remains were in there it's really
terrible yeah I mean we have churches in
African-American neighborhoods where the
KKK and Christian terrorists group
killed people I don't really understand
the difference the KKK is not a it's not
a religious organization yeah they
perform Christian terrorism very they're
not they're not a Christian organization
they are not doing what they're doing in
the name of
Jesus they're not scream screaming Jesus
is greater as they're killing people
they're not I certainly wouldn't suggest
putting a a KKK Shrine uh on uh 16th
Street in in you know by by where those
black children were killed certainly not
and I I wouldn't I would be just as I
would be just as vocal against it but
it's not a religious issue yeah I really
want to understand the argument you're
making and I don't understand how I I I
feel that you're equating all Islam with
extreme Muslim terrorists and can you
explain to me how if you do believe that
they're different well they are
different yeah as many of the Muslims
that have written to me saying that they
believe it's a bad idea it's a bad idea
I mean they're going to build it just so
that you know they're going to build
it uh but it is it's insulting and it's
offensive to build a shrine to the very
ideology that inspired the attacks of
9/11 and many Muslims understand
this uh they don't think it's a
particularly good idea I mean all of
this Discord and disunity uh is a result
of this idea what was the
point I what was the point and then you
have uh on many of the audio tapes that
I got you have uh Imam rou extoling the
work of sha kwi a notorious
anti-American anti-west uh anti-semite
uh is this who we're going to have speak
at the Islamic Center sh
kwi I I'm just tell you're going to
remember this particular moment it's a
bad idea
yeah anti um I wonder do you think that
there's a problem with um like anti
Muslim in this country and um
particularly the MOs um there were a lot
of other MOS across the
country um I do not believe there's an
anti-muslim I think there's a counter
Jihad and rightly so I mean Jihad is
harmful to living things um as far as
the mosques that were you say mosques
were attacked in other cities I have to
say just so that you know according to
the latest FBI
report uh hate crimes against Muslim and
is at its lowest since this is check
everybody check everything that I say I
insist by the
way FBI report latest report a uh
anti-muslim uh hate crime is uh at its
lowest since 9111 um uh versus
anti-semitic attacks that are 10 times
higher record Hearts uh I'm not I don't
believe in any I don't believe in hate
crimes just know vly against all crime
and think it should be prosecuted to the
full extense of the law by the same
token I don't believe you should
prosecute for hate
crimes I don't I think that crime should
be prosecuted but what is a hate
crime what is a hate what is a hate
crime you're calling somebody a name
look at the end of the day okay it's an
encroachment on Free Speech if somebody
does something illegal they should be
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
but who decides what's hate speech and
what's protected speech look it's easy
to protect the speech that we like it's
easy that's a no-brainer it's a speech
we don't like that needs protection
because then who's going to decide who's
going to decide what's good and what's
forbidden the government the UN who
question
um so I agree I'm huge
per say um but I do think hate crimes
it's not just about what you say it's
the fact that you're shuring your
intention for committing a crime you be
murder or assault thought crime that's
even scarier no but I'm saying if you
actually commit the crime if you
actually if you actually commit the
crime you should pay the highest penalty
against if you commit a crime against a
person a society property you have to
you have to it must be crimes are to
send a message to a larger group grou
you know you're attacking Muslim not
that you're murdering Muslim you're
doing show that other Muslims H the same
way that
they're it's it's a message if a Muslim
or a Jew or a Christian or a Hindu or a
zarrian is attacked they should be
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
H you don't think there's something more
Sinister in trying to send a message no
I mean look if a girl is called fat I
think that's a hate crime I'm serious if
those called
ugly I where are you going to draw the
line I'm I'm saying there's a difference
between I understand what you're saying
about speech and that calling person
that is the same thing but I mean
there's something different when you
attach an intention to an actual violent
attack when the actual violent attack
must be prosecuted to the full extent of
the law and if there's a conspiracy to
commit some kind of illegal act oh yes
conspiracy is against the law
if there's a real conspiracy I mean yeah
yeah um one of your main reasons against
the proposed mosque is that it's
insulting and that seems like a very
subjective claim to me uh for example
like I consider myself as much an
American as you are and I don't find it
insulting at all you're young um it's
it's off look it is offensive and over
70% of the American people strongly
oppose the mosque and I think that you
can't just dismiss that and I also think
the discussion must be had this disc and
M will be built as I said but I think
this discussion must be had and I think
the lack of sensitivity when this Uber
sensitivity is demanded of us is the
height of hypocrisy and supremacism
because where's the mutual and mutual
respect where's the mutual and mutual
tolerance where's where's the tolerance
it's it's only goes one way the bridge
is a one-way Bridge uh somebody that I
have gentlemen um if I may use your
language if we were to stop building
mosque who is it that would decide what
exactly is offensive and what in in
offensive for instance could someone um
could a Muslim pray at Ground Zero is
that okay or how like far Ground Zero
all the time they pray same but it's not
the same look it's not the same thing
pray at Ground Zero all the time there
are two or three other mosques in the
neighborhood you've never heard any
utter boo about them a 15 story Mosk
looking down so who decides what floor
level it become offensive looking down
and ground z a mega mosque is offensive
I mean you can make the joke of it but
the fact is a giant mosque at Ground
Zero I mean we can sit here and you know
analyze the nitty-gritty but a 15 story
mosque Ground Zero is deliberately
provocative and yes it is an act of of
Conquest particularly when you come up
against all of this opposition and you
will not even consider it you will not
meet with the 911 families you will not
meet with the governor this is
supremacism I me we're always talk about
dialogue dialogue dialogue only one
way uh anyone that hasn't asked a
question then I'll go be Happ to go back
to repeat gentlemen yeah uh I just um
I'd agree with a lot of your logic about
um sorry uh just about your free speech
and you know crime Cal FS you know um
but I feel like it's a little uh
hypocritical to not then apply that to
the mosque at Ground Zero
um more specifically I sort of mean like
uh um just you
want say like the KKK I mean so
basically um if if the KKK moved in
across the street from like the N ACP
that would be uncomfortable um but you
argue that like free speech is so
important I mean don't you think that
that once we start deciding who is
allowed to be where then it's sort of
just a slippery slope and we can but we
do decide don't we you in the way you're
depicting the KKK with the Snicker
across the room have decided about the
KKK you've made a
judgment and how is the KKK really
defeated I will tell you how it was
defeated Society przed them at the turn
of the 20th century I don't know the
exact statistic but it's very high for
the number one out of four or two out of
eight when Americans were members of the
KKK and then when their acts became more
well known Society paried them Society
relegated them into the very fringes of
decent society and so now when you say
KKK everyone's like Snick is terrible
well I think that she had should be
relegated to the very fringes of society
not building 15 shrines looking down on
the attack the greatest Jihadi attack on
the West in history I mean it just seems
like on one hand you're saying 70% of
Americans uh are against the mosque
because okay so they oppose the mosque
and because of that majority that's
enough to say that it shouldn't be built
whereas I could say that equally 70% of
Americans could oppose the KKK but they
are allowed to build something near endl
ACP I mean it seems like specifically
they allowed to build a mask okay but so
you seem less upset about you expect
more sensitivity from the KKK than you
do from the ground zero mosque I I
expect equal sensitivity and it seems
like you're targeting well I don't
expect sensitivity from the KKK I I I I
don't expect sensitivity from them I
think that they're a vile society and I
don't I don't assign the same human
decency and the same human qualities to
the KKK as I would um an organization uh
dedicated to Human Rights just seems
like once you start deciding um that
because the majority disagrees with them
that they shouldn't be allowed to exist
that that's just sort of I didn't say
they shouldn't be allowed to exist it
works but so it's not against I mean you
believe in like fulfilling the you know
there should be prosecut full the law
you believe in you know you're against
Crime but so if it's not illegal to
build this mosque it's not illegal to
build this MOS I've never invoked it
I've never said it was illegal I said it
I quote they should move it and I know
that there are the powers that be like
Patterson and many members uh in in
government who help them do it I mean
you know Donald Trump offered them a 1.5
million or $2 million bonus to move it
the way they're digging in their heels I
think is is wrong I don't think it
should have gotten to this point to be
honest with you when I organized the
first rally June 6th I have to be honest
with you I expected a couple hundred
people I never expect expected upwards
to 10,000 people this is visceral this
is painful it's painful look like I said
they're going to build it but I think
that it's an enormously bad idea and I
think that it's done a good deal of harm
to to these relationships that are so
exalted this girl who had hand up for a
while um I guess I just see
contradiction even in your own
terminologic like earlier in your
presentation you said that like wom that
out girl will draw Mohamad day and that
we should like protect her speech even
though people thought that it was
offensive and that like maybe the most
like hateful vile speech should be
protected even though it might be
offensive to like everyone but your
argument is essentially the to you and
so it's not like I'm not asking is it
truly offensive or is it not but like
why in this case of what you see is like
the most offensive possible sign of
religious expression should we still not
uphold the right to Religious Freedom
that you would voke in I do uphold the
right to Religious Freedom no no I know
but I mean like you're actively starting
a campaign to say that they shouldn't be
allowed to worship there or that they
shouldn't choose toship there they
should move the mosque it's just
essentially that they should move the
Mosk they don't have to uh I certainly
would not inv invoke any law but yes I
still I I believe it they should move
the mask America was attacked a
slaughtered I don't know if any of you I
don't know how old you are so you were
what nine 10 you
were any of you in the city at the
time so the
stench of Steel and plastic and human
flesh that hung in this city
a
months it's a bad idea no one's saying
they can't do it but in in the interest
of
furthering this sort of
uh marriage in between Islam and America
why would you do that why would you do
it they're going to do it they're going
to do it um uh and they're going to do
it despite all of the pain and the grief
it is pain it is it is it's a very very
painful
idea and they that they want to break
ground on September
11th uh that they're calling it The the
Cordova I mean this is just one club to
the Head Club to the heart after another
and I I guess it's I don't know if it's
laudable to fight for this right um but
I just find it so
inhumane that's it that's where the
argument stops at that and it's not as
if they made an attempt like oh you know
we didn't know it was going to hurt so
many people uh we'll move it so many
opportunities to move it um and they
have not even met with with the governor
they haven't even considered it why why
did you feet dig your heels in like that
I mean if if if the shoe was on the
other foot and this was America
I mean I I imagine that you would be
excoriating America for not being
sensitive to X yo Z but this blanket
this tcid sanction of so radical and
extreme an ideology it surprises me that
the young carries the water for so
radical and extreme in ideology it does
because you're supposed to be you know
the bearers of all things liberal
freedom and so on um
yes talked a lot about
the West
oftion do you think good distinction to
make still like in terms of America
trying to you know cooperate you know a
global setting do you think it's a good
idea to make the distinction between
East and West well it's not a distinct
it's a reality Western values are
reality uh and certainly I think the
best system uh human governance and
human ideals uh it took centuries
centuries of thought and blood and toil
uh to get to this place in history and I
don't believe in subjugating women and I
don't believe that women of property and
I don't believe that saying it is makes
me uh a bad person I extol Western
values and I am a I am a an advocate of
American exceptionalism to your point
about American exceptionalism I don't
know if you knew that you making that
point um do I believe in American
exceptionalism versus international law
or internationalism yes um yeah I
do I believe in American exceptionalism
because America was founded on the basic
principle of individual rights
everything Noble and great and
magnificent and just that this country
achieved was a logical Fidelity to that
principle so when people speak about
American exceptionalism what they're
really saying is individual
exceptionalism America was the first
government in human history the first
moral government in the history of man
that was based on individual rights so
it's not that it's American
exceptionalism but it's the idea of
individual rights that makes us
exceptional and everything that we've
achieved is a direct result of that and
I certainly uh uh believe in that well
over international law because with
international law what is international
law is it the UN well the UN is by and
large driven by the largest block of
countries there's one block the OIC the
organization of Islamic conference 57
Nations and they vote as one block and
so they're voting to restrict Free
Speech under the Sharia to not defame
Islam and for the first time in in
American history the US president
co-sponsored uh a restriction of free
speech resolution in the UN with Egypt I
don't think that's a good thing is there
an organization of Christian Conference
at the UN no there's not is there an
organization of Jewish conference it be
three guys in a deli no there is not
there's an organization of Christian of
Islamic conference that drives the bus
now because they're the largest block of
voting Nations so to your question
absolutely not I I believe in American
sovereignty and I think that America has
been a Force for good now you can you
can I know you're going to throw some
America America she ain't perfect she
ain't perfect but she's the best that
you won't like what what comes after
America you may all be you know working
what was that are there things that you
think that we can learn from the
East I think there are things they can
learn from us but that's not my
question the East is it's two what do we
are talking bu Buddhism I I mean you
have to be more specific well I mean you
were the one who made the distinction
between the East and the West so I ask
Western values I didn't mention East I
meant Western values versus all other
versus all yeah I I I believe it's the
super
ior uh civilization I'm asking in the
way that you view it between East and
West do you think that there are things
that the E offers I think that we can
all learn from each
other but I want to live here
yes yes well I'd like to thank you for
being here my question uh no matter how
much I might view points I think it take
some some good spot to get up there and
get and take our question but I was just
wondering
uh you you mentioned that you you take
issue with some of what im Ralph uh in
his invation of the U Shia yes and I
just want to uh like I I think I'm
starting to understand your your logic
on that
uh whether or not it's a first amend
right exising right now whether or not
he he should build it uh to look over
Ground Zero I was just wondering would
you would you take offense toov you say
you wouldn't take offense in moving his
or his community center elsewhere but do
you not think of that as a threat if he
is someone who is
invoking radical Muslim ideology or do
we not
have I think the Sharia is very
dangerous I
do do I see it as a threat in the west
only if we don't fight for our own
Constitution only if we don't only if we
we don't fight for our own system of
governance I mean I think the I think
the Constitution is as perfect almost as
perfect a
document that you could get really one
of the most magnificent documents ever
written really in human history uh but
it's worthless if you don't you know
there's nothing wrong with the
Constitution it's if you don't adhere to
it or if you're constantly you know sort
of you know know twisting it and what
have you um if if there are countries
like the 57 Muslim countries that choose
to live under the Sharia that's their
business but I certainly don't believe
that it belongs here and I have no
problem with religion you you can
worship a stone just don't Stone me with
it and so as I understood s's question
yeah if if this guy's ideology
represents such a fundamental threat
surely it would represent a thre there
were 10 blocks from ground Z every bit
as much as it would it were two blocks
from it doesn't the logic of your
position suggests that it should be
challenged perhaps limited no matter
where it exists if indeed it's as
threatening as you said well I do
believe it's threatening I guess one has
to convince the majority of the
population such there are a great many
imams that um extol Jihad uh look every
single Islamic attack of the ,000 odd
attacks since 911 each one has the infat
of a Muslim cleric each one of those
jihadis were devout and belong to a
mosque and had the impat of a Muslim
cleric that is a problem I think it's a
separate problem from the ground zero
mosque I mean the ground zero mos in and
of itself now are a lot of issues coming
out related to that yes there are but I
just think the ground zero mosque a huge
mosque at Ground Zero is just a very uh
painful you stab in the eye uh now as
far as the threat that this violent
ideology or like a um chowy ad chowy in
in the UK or many of these these uh
radical and extreme imams present yes
it's a
problem uh what we're going to do about
that from a legislative or what have you
point of view you got to hope that uh
goodness wins out you you have to hope
that the good will you know and the Free
Will Triumph but as far as this MOS goes
uh you know I are you going to tie it
into that are you going to tie it into
into like okay what are you going to do
now about all the radical mosques and
the extremist Dem moms I don't know I
think that's too big an issue to tie to
it that's just my
take yeah well like to that point we've
already had an Islamic Cultural Center
on the upper west side for like I think
it's been twoes now so you would then I
say that that should stay or on the
posing point that we don't want to have
this never said it shouldn't stay so I
never spoke I never there are hundreds
of mosques and Islamic centers thousands
in America um
again but specifically in New York and
DC because that's where they were hit at
911 was that building that the Islamic
Center in destroyed in the 911 attacks
no
okay I have a problem with that I have a
problem with a building that was
destroyed in the attacks and I believe
that's why it was
chosen in the back to the
left
no it is not fair to do that I mean I
happen to know from an internal poll
which probably your family members took
part in a 911 family member poll uh the
large majority opposed the mosque uh
clearly there are going to be people
with all different opinions there's no
question about it and as I said this is
a just a human relationship issue
uh you know and and and they have the
support you see you know Imam rou is up
the time magazines Man of the Year you
know Sharif Al Gamal who you know was a
waiter a couple of years ago has no
money has defaulted on two not one but
two bank loans um he's NBC's person of
the here so clearly you have the the the
controlling the information controlling
force uh behind the ask there's no
question about it but you are allowed
you're entitled to your feelings you are
entitled to be heard you're entitled to
your grief particularly after that
day yes um
so it's provocative yeah so I about
the
so a bus ad that sh says Ground Zero why
there with a picture of the towers as a
with the plane approaching and a picture
of the ground zero mque that's offensive
but a ground zero mque is
not a bus ad that runs for 3 weeks to
ask the question why there that's
essentially the question why there why
create this wh why there this incredible
amount of unhappiness I think it's great
that you guys are out there you know
fighting for the right they have the
right there's no fight they going to
build I
think I think that theage
of also seen
as victim in fact had a victim of the
ATT died here on lond
she put
on okay so
now it's offensive to run a historical
photo is this go through the Pearl Har
to and and and Civil War and ioimo that
that the picture of a historical event
and by the way the buset that she's
referring to I was prohibited from
running originally because 911 images
were
banned I was was so struck by
that I was
shocked I said what do you mean expand
this is American history this happened
to us you can't use
picture I said what do I have to do to
use the picture they said take out the
plane so I removed the plane and it was
rejected again I said why are you
rejecting it again they said well
there's some smoke in the background got
to take out the
smoke I took out the smoke I wanted the
air to run because the media was doing
its best to shape the the the narrative
so I wanted the I took out the
smoke and there was two towers Crystal
Clear day and it's true in the corner
there was a tiny little plane just a
plane in the corner tiny like right you
got to go take out the plane I what are
you saying it's a plane it's on the
other side of the of the sky it's a
plane planes fly planes were flying over
New York before 911 they to take it out
so I submitted the ad just the towers no
nothing clear day no plane and still
they wouldn't take the air and I sued
them on Friday night and they caved on
Monday morning because it is a free
speech issue so we can run images of 911
but they can build a a 15 story Mega
mosque and that's not insulting and
that's not offensive do you see
it yeah um you speak about like the
reciprocity or that there is no reoc
that we're only preserving um that we're
only preserving you know not offending
Muslims but would you say this would be
rather a better position to just say
that everybody can say what they want
like you can maybe run a bus at but they
can also build a m why is the solution
to this like media run Narrative of only
helping Muslims a reason for you same
things why not just p position from a
respect of people being able to do what
they want
all we they can we're just having a
dialogue yeah
I how do you feel about that
marginalizing or alienating Muslims that
cre I I don't see a marginalization to
be honest with you they're completely
free here they're Freer here than
anywhere else in the world and there are
many Muslims that are not free to speak
out against these things because they're
vilified within their own communities we
have to make it safe for them we have to
make it safe for all Muslims not just
those that are trying to impose their
own agenda but there are those that are
maybe trying to leave there are
apostates that live under death threat I
know because I'm involved in getting
them to safe houses that everybody is
entitled to the same protected rights
this is America no special rights for
special classes period I don't believe
in marginalizing anybody I want everyone
to be as free as you and me every day
every breath they take that's why I do
what I do
period
yeah you talk about like individual
rights and how our country kind of
deserves that do you see that only
happening in this country like um how
about like our International relation
policies with the Middle East our like
support of
are coped on people that did um propose
policies that may have not been Pro
American but they were supported by the
majority of people well I am an
individual rights advocate so you will
not hear me supporting uh the uh uh
America supporting um dictators regimes
I do not believe in foreign aid to
countries where it just lines the C the
pockets of the fat cats and the never
gets to the people and I couldn't agree
with you more we should not be giving
Aid what what we should be doing and
what you should be doing and what the
peace course should be doing is teaching
political freedom and teaching
individual rights and that's what we
should be exporting and so to your point
I thoroughly agree thoroughly agree with
you and I think we need a a
major um shift in our our F foreign
policy um
uh motives you see and so you won't get
any argument for me there none
whatsoever yes you said the MOs be built
U definitely and kind of there's no
fight so going forward kind of what is
your end goal well if it's definitely
going to be built like yeah I think
question why I think it's going to be
built but we're still going to we're
going to voice our opposition I mean
next uh December 14th the New York City
Council has declared hate Walmart day
this is the New York City government has
declared hate Walmart day and they
holding hearing and we will be at that
hearing and we will Pro be protesting
the mosque at that hearing where you'll
be completely hypocritical you won't get
involved in the mosque but you're
stopping Walmart there's a Kmart Penn
Station there's a Home Depot there's a
Lowe's but you're Banning Walmart now
I'm not I don't own stock in Walmart I
don't know anybody at Walmart I don't
care about Walmart but I think that I
think people should know what their
government is
doing yeah your
arity
this was according to an internal poll
of the 9/11 families
yeah yeah well America didn't think it
was a good idea and they were wrong they
were wrong on their face and America
didn't think it was a good idea I don't
care what the Americans have thought we
beat
them they
lost and that was long overdue that was
long
overdue oh no I agree I totally concur I
I totally concur I do not believe in M
Rule and uh I'm not suggesting it or
implying it but clearly America was
attacked
it was the wor worst attack ever we're
suffering every day every day you don't
know what it was like to travel when I
was younger you don't know you don't
have a clue how fabulous it was you
actually get dressed to go to the
airport I mean it was really excited and
and and yeah and nobody broke you and
nobody it wasn't like going into the gab
I mean or or or going into a building in
New York
City you know where you weren't carded
to go into building in New York City
your life has changed in ways you don't
even know you don't know what it's like
to really be
free I think it's terrible what's going
on at the airports the groping I what
now they're internally planting bombs in
in in in the sphin what are you what are
they going to do then they going have
proctologists at the airport
screening this is no way to win a war
and it is a war and it's costing us a
bloody Fortune this this operation fetal
position
[Music]
yeah terrorist 91 I didn't I didn't
imply the 19 Muslim terrorists screaming
Al akar as they crash their planes into
the buildings they employed it not me I
mean
actually greater it's a superior
thing certainly example of extr doesn't
that simply
equate Islam ex with simple Islam
worship no I mean I don't see it that
way I don't I'm not
collectively uh because there are many
Muslims in my
camp but that attack was inspired by
ji and so you can't not equate the two
and he Iman rou in the first article in
the New York Times on December 8th 2009
said that quote New York City is the
capital of the world and that building
is Iconic of 911 he tied
it
don't I don't believe every Muslim is a
jihadist do you no I don't understand
I don't understand whyos is
offensive
symbolize it's really very
simple I don't see it as simp I I
understand that you don't see I
understand that you don't see it as
simple but it really is very simple I
these were acts um uh of jihad inspired
by Islam that went into the towers and
wiped out this city and do you really
believe for one second that they thought
that the buildings were going to invert
in explosion they meant to take out all
of L and Manhattan and should we tear
down all the churches in Jerusalem no
but you don't you don't on all the
churches in Jerusalem why would you do
that because of the Crusades and
thousands upon thousands of people that
were massacred many many the Christians
are not killing the Jews now I mean
they're not killing the Jew now right
now we're in this war those wars were
fought those fought one lost done we're
here now and I and like I said that
mosque will be
filt and you'll
see the repercussions of such in your
lifetime more so than I even will and
again I will say I mean why not
reconsider could you imagine if you
reconsider for a second just bear with
me if he reconsidered he met with the
governor probably got a better deal cuz
you know they're going to Juice It Up
right and that would have been that and
how much Good Will would that have
created really that gesture of kindness
and Humanity that's all it is is a
gesture of kindness and Humanity
wouldn't that but no I telling you he
will not move that mosque he won't
because it is an act of Islamic
supremacism it is not all mosques are
acts of Islamic supremacism but you
cannot deny that there is this strain in
Islam you cannot deny the 2 million in
Sudan this is a Jihad do you know it's a
Jihad you cannot deny the millions are
dead they're dead how you must you must
have some compassion you must have some
desire to know why these people are
being slaughtered you and the freest of
all countries who live such free and
unfed lives the only thing that fed is
your life or whatever you fed yourself
with it is up to us it is up to us you
cannot assume your freom
you cannot you must fight for
it
yes religious liberty religious
Liberties
issue I wish I had known I wish I add
some I'd like you to see the bus bus ad
the bus ad
says Ground
Zero why
there and it has on the left the
towers uh on the day of 911 September
11th
2011 and it had at the time the
rendering of the mosque which was
supposed to break ground according to
Daisy Khan in May of 201 10 in USA Today
in the Daily News to breakr September
11th 2011 10 year anniversary
which I find to be spectacularly
outrageous that's the
end I cannot believe that anybody in
this room who believes that the n The
Ground Zero musque is a good idea could
take issue with an ad like
that if one is not a problem that
certainly
is nothing and I don't believe that
those images should be
embargoed who are we
protecting we were attack it's not awful
you don't have to hide it's like a rape
victim who doesn't go to the authorities
you don't have to hide question yeah um
so saying
ask
right um did you ever see the piece by I
did you did right it's a book it's a
book it's a book I remember her
publishing
it
yeah she wrote a four straight days she
just sat wrot one of the most famous
greatest the cury anyway she she writes
this piece about specific example um in
Italy in her hometown where uh Muslims
had put up a tent and for a holiday um
and for a month they had and ex and all
of this was piling up and she called
ministers and she called whoever and
they AG they wouldn't move or they
wouldn't move the tent until she finally
called police station and said I've been
to Wars I know how to will use it
tomorrow okay the point is she called
herself racist and she she said that was
okay how do you
not as
rist lahi can call herself what she
wants I am not a racist because I
believe in individual rights you see I
believe in individualism so I look at a
person and I look at them as the entire
unit who are they what are they are they
what are their actions by their fruits
you shall know them and so I know him I
I I don't I I'm not taking it on on on I
I don't take I don't believe in racism I
think it's a I think it's a fantasy not
racism itself but the whole idea of
racism I mean that one is superior to
someone else because their fingernails
are blue or their skin is brown or it's
it's a ridiculous notion I don't buy it
but I do believe that there are people
that wish to impede impair call
uh provide obstacles to uh freedom and
women's rights and so on and so on and
this is what I this is what I fight for
and I wish that someone like Imam Ra was
fighting against the Sharia that was
speaking against let's say the 96% of
women in Egypt that have been
clitorois against the thousands of
apostates that have been murdered I mean
I would love to see a a huge voice in
Islam coming out against the fatwa
issued against uh converts out of Islam
from Alazar University the leading
Islamic University in the world against
apostates I uh I welcome that and and
voices that do speak that way are
vilified I mean Muslims in the Muslim
world that speak out against this are
vilified and demonized um falach you
know she was first you know she was
first out there with all of this stuff
and if you're going to read it you
really should read you know the force of
reason as well um but she can call us
what she wants so so so Pam um
unfortunately we're going to have a
break soon and I I'm going to take my
poal prerogative and have the
last first of all the most important
Last Words is just to thank you thank
you for sharing your views your thank
you for having me your passions and for
being civil I appreciate it enormously
hugely important um uh to me as a
teacher as an American um two two things
that struck me um first of all one theme
throughout your remarks um was that you
want to is Islam and you try to
differentiate at different points
between jihadists and other Muslims
between Muslims that you found
reasonable and unreasonable Muslims be
found decent and indecent I hear that
but it strikes me that you weaken you
weakened your position by voting the
correct um and if I were you I would
stay away from that and here's
why but but but you know indeed you
acknowledge that people interpret that
scripture differently so by you you can
interpret that scripture differently
that scripture is the word of Allah
unlike the Old Testament and the New
Testament I know time is of the essence
but it's important to know that the
Bible is really collection of stories uh
versus the Quran which is Allah giving
his word to uh Muhammad and Muhammad
writing it down it is uncreated you
cannot reinterpret the qur you cannot it
is not only is it uh not allowed but the
penalty for reinterpretation or or
hypocrisy
that's I would just say as an empirical
matter I think it would be quite easy to
show that many different Muslims around
the world interpret that do in many
different well they're not orig they're
not pure islamists you know it's not
pure Islam yes Ah that's precis my point
right that there are different ways of
interpreting the do no they're just not
adhering to that they're choosing not to
adhere but according to the good Muslims
those Muslims that are not purists are
not real Muslims and those Muslims as in
Sudan they get slaughtered they get
slaughtered the second the second uh
kind of theme that I thought would came
up was really interesting it's the one
of of sensitivity and insult um because
you know it's it strikes me that
precisely that that that one of the
themes in conservative America has to do
with this Trope of PC and what PC does
is it creates all sorts of informal
codes that make us worry about offending
each other and I hear that too but
that's why I thought it was so ironic
that so much of your argument was
phrased about the offense that you and
others felt aren't you in some way
actually reinforcing the doctrine of PC
ex such the thing exists by so much of
what you say about the I'm so not py um
I really thought of this and still think
of this as a basic human issue and
people can insult me and I get insulted
on a daily basis believe me and I don't
even take offense at more I don't care
but this is this was something to me all
very very different because there are
these issues and there is this war going
on so why do this now I mean it just
didn't make and still doesn't make any I
want to thank Pam for